bueno Franco una de las primeras medidas
de olab shorts al llegar al poder fue
cambiar no la histórica posición
armamentística y militar del país y
recibió muchísimas críticas por la lenta
reacción ante desafíos como el de
Ucrania no la demora en autorizar el
envío de los tanques a kiev como lo deja
posicionado al canciller alemán te hablo
en términos de política interna
para entender el daño o la ventaja que
pudo haber sacado Hola joels tomando
esta decisión hay que poner el ojo en
otra batalla que no es la de kiev y no
es la de Ucrania sino que es la
comunicacional hay dos narrativas en
Alemania que compiten una es la del
gobierno la de olafones la de en
particular el partido socialdemócrata
que hablaba lo que había sobre lo que
veíamos en el informe de no precipitarse
de esperar de no tomar decisiones en en
Soledad no y esperar que los aliados
acompañen y esa decisión sea conjunta es
decir producto de la diplomacia y por el
otro lado otra narrativa de la oposición
de algunos algunas Voces del gobierno y
también de otros actores de la comunidad
internacional e incluso de medios de
comunicación de Alemania que hablaban de
que no se podía esperar de que la
situación demanda que el gobierno tome
esa decisión de efectivamente enviar
esos tanques en función de El dominio
que haya conseguido alguna de esas dos
narrativas se podría llegar a sacar
conclusiones en cuanto al daño que ha
tenido Alemania dentro de su propio país
es decir de Cara a la opinión pública y
lo que vemos pese a la discusión que que
se observan los medios y que pareciera
que que habría una decisión que el
gobierno estaría retardando cuando
miramos los estudios de opinión pública
muy recientes de este mes de hace unos
pocos días vemos que hay una división
muy importante también la población
cuarenta y tres por ciento estarían a
favor del envío y cuarenta y tres por
ciento estarían en contra del envío no
Entonces eso no termina de alguna manera
de dejar bien o mal posicionado al
canciller al menos de Cara a la opinión
pública porque es la propia población
alemana que también está dividida
respecto de esta decisión te quería
preguntar también a qué se expone
Alemania en términos quizás de
represalias por parte de Rusia tomando
esta medida no
Bueno eso es una una de las grandes
discusiones esa es uno de de alguna
manera de los grandes argumentos de la
socialdemocracia liderada por el
canciller olafones de no precipitarse no
y de no permitir que con este movimiento
Vladimir vladimirovich Putin tenga una
excusa para efectivamente escalar el
conflicto teniendo en cuenta que Hay
ciertos elementos digamos que
actualmente no se pueden terminar de
de predecir no En ese sentido porque
había muchas personas por ejemplo que
pensaban que esta guerra nunca iba a
tener lugar y tuvo lugar en ese sentido
es interesante para mí poner el ojo Si
volvemos a al impacto en la opinión
pública en este comportamiento Con esta
forma de tomar decisiones del gobierno
alemán y en particular del cancillers
porque pese a pertenecer a otro partido
político el competidor se parece mucho a
la forma de toma de decisiones de la
propia Angela Merkel que muchas crisis
siempre se tomó el tiempo necesario
incluso hasta hasta un punto casi de no
retorno para efectivamente decidir en
una o en otra dirección y esto lo
estamos viendo ahora con el gobierno
actual Ale